people have figured out oh if this ratio
was different by some Factor like a
factor of two or something I was like oh
this would all like not work and I look
you look at the sun right it's like so
it turns out that there are key
reactions that if they had slightly
lower probability no star would ever
ignite and then life wouldn't be
possible it does seem like the the
universe set things up for us that it's
possible to do some cool things but it's
challenging so that that keeps it fun
for us yeah yeah that's the way I look
at it I mean the you know the Multiverse
model is an interesting one uh because
there are you know Quantum scientists
who look at and fear I was like oh it's
like oh yeah like Quantum science
perhaps tells us that there are almost
an infinite you know variety of other
universes but the way that it works
probably is it's almost like a form of
natural selection it's like well the
universes that didn't have the correct
or interesting relationships between
these forces nothing happens in them so
almost by definition the fact fact that
we're having this conversation means
that we're in one of the interesting
ones by default
yeah one of the somewhat interesting but
there's probably super interesting ones
where we I I tend to think of humans as
incredible creatures our brain is is an
incredible Computing device but
I think we're also extremely cognitively
limited I can imagine
alien civilizations that are much much
much much more intelligent in ways we
can't even comprehend in terms of their
ability to come to construct models of
the world and to do physics to do
physics and Mathematics I would see it
in a slightly different way it's
actually it's because we have
um we have we have creatures that live
with us on the earth that have cognition
right that understand and move through
their environment but they they actually
see things in a way or they sense things
in a way which is so fundamentally
different it's really hard like the TR
it's the problem is the translation not
necessarily intelligence so it's the
perception of the world so I have a dog
and when I go out and I see my dog like
smelling things there's a realization
that I have that he sees or senses the
world in a way that I can never like I
can't understand it because I can't
translate my way to this we get little
glimpses of this as humans though by the
way because there are some parts of it
for example Optical information which
comes from light isn't now because we've
developed the technology we can actually
see things you know I've had I get this
you know as a one of my areas of
research is spectroscopy so this means
the study of light you know and I and I
get this quote unquote see things or
representation of them from you know the
far infrared all the way to like hard
hard x-rays which is several orders of
magnitude of the of the light intensity
but our own human eyes like see a teeny
teeny little sliver of this yeah so that
even like bees for example see a
different place than we do so I don't I
I think if you think of there's already
other intelligences like around us in a
way in a limited way
um because of the way they can
communicate but it's like those are
already baffling in many ways yeah so if
we just focus in on the senses there's
already a lot of diversity but there's
probably things we're not even
considering as possibilities for example
uh whatever the heck Consciousness is
could actually be a door into
understanding some physical phenomena
we're not I haven't even begun
understanding so just like you said
spectroscopy there could be a similar
kind of spectrum for Consciousness that
we're just like we're like these dumb uh
the descendants of Apes like walking
around it sure feels like something to
experience the color red but like we
don't have
it's the same as in the ancient times
you experience physics you experience
light it's like oh it's bright and you
know yeah yeah and you construct kind of
uh what's interesting we might actually
experience this faster than we thought
because we might be building another
another kind of intelligence yeah and
that that intelligence will explain to
us how silly we are there was an email
thread going around the professors in my
department already of uh so what is it
going to look like to figure out if
students have actually written their
term papers or it's chat GPT
um uh it was so as usual as it is where
you we tend to be empiricists in my
field so of course they were in there
like trying to figure out if uh if it
could answer like questions for a
qualifying exam to get into the PHD
program
tea which was they didn't do that well
at that point but of course this is just
the beginning of it so we have some
interesting ones to go eventually both
the students and the professors will be
replaced by Chad GPT yeah and we'll sit
on the beach I really recommend you know
this I don't know if you've ever seen
them it's called the day the universe
changed
this is James Burke he's a science
historian based in the UK um he had a
had a fairly famous series on on public
television called connections I think it
was but the one that I really enjoyed
was the day the universe uh changed and
the the reason for the title of it was
that
um he says the universe is what we know
and perceive of it so when there's a
fundamental insight as to something new
the universe for us changes of course
the universe from an objective point of
view is the same as it was before but
for us it has changed so he walks
through these these moments of
perception in in in in the history of
humanity that like changed what we were
right and so as I was thinking about
coming to to discuss this you know
people see Fusion oh it's still far away
or we've been it's been slow progress
It's like when my when my godmother was
born like people had no idea how Stars
worked
so you talk about like that day that
Insight the universe changed it's like
oh this is the I mean and they still
didn't understand all the parts of it
but you know they basically got it it's
like oh because of the because of the
understanding of these processes it's
like we unveiled the reason that there
can be life in the universe that's
probably one of those days the universe
changed right yeah